[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
60 18 26 minutes d'actualité locale nous
sommes le jeudi 6 février voici les
titres le déplacement ce matin dans les
yvelines de geneviève darrieussecq la
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
des armées s'est rendu notamment au
lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
visite sur place d'un chantier de
sécurisation du site
9e jour de grève interprofessionnelle
contre la réforme des retraites les
avocats aussi sont mobilisés avec
plusieurs centaines d'audience reporter
au barreau de versailles
le premier ministre leur a fait des
propositions hier pour sortir du conflit
et puis la page consacrée aux élections
municipales à magny les hameaux il
pourrait y avoir trois candidats
l'ancien conseiller municipal dominique
grattepain tente de constituer son
équipe autour de la liste manie le bon
sens quelques idées de sorties à faire
aussi ce week-end dans les yvelines a
retrouvé tout à l'heure dans ce journal
[Musique]
je vous le disais dans les titres
geneviève darrieussecq était ce matin au
lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école la
secrétaire d'état auprès de la ministre
des armées est venu faire un point
d'étape sur le chantier lancé dans le
cadre du plan lycée le reportage daury
lyons
pas d'odeur le faire correctement
première pierre pour ce bâtiment qui
offrira dès la rentrée prochaine 180
places d'hébergement aux élèves du lycée
militaire de saint-cyr coût de ces
travaux est 7 millions d'euros ils sont
entièrement financés par le plan lycée
lancé par la secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre des armées
nous avons besoin de conserver ses
infrastructures en bon état nous avons
pérennisé celis et pérenniser
l'enseignement qu'il y avait à
l'intérieur de ces lycées et même
augmenter les filières possibles et donc
nous avions besoin de travailler sur les
infrastructures dont certaines étaient
sont très vieillissante et nécessite
vraiment des améliorations ce bâtiment
modulaire de 2000 m² et la première
infrastructure nouvelle qui voit le jour
dans le cadre du plan lycée évolutif il
accueillera dans un second temps des
salles de cours donc on a en charge ses
travaux et par la suite d'autres travaux
qui en découlent dans notamment la
rénovation d'un bâtiment complet de
chambre et
les sanitaires de tous les internats
dans le bâtiment ancien qui date de
l'après guerre la france compte sur son
territoire six établissements de la
défense plus de 110 millions d'euros
vont ainsi être consacrés jusqu'en 2025
à l'amélioration des conditions de
travail et de vie des élèves et des
enseignants à la grève contre la réforme
des retraites a passé le deuxième mois
de contestation aujourd'hui c'était la
huitième journée de mobilisation
interprofessionnelle
et depuis un mois les avocats aussi sont
engagés dans le conflit on en parle avec
mme mandine blondin bonsoir ça vous êtes
avocate au barreau de versailles
une grève qui dure le premier ministre
edouard philippe vous a fait notamment
des propositions hier on va en parler
tout à l'heure pour sortir du conflit
quelles conséquences ça concrètement sur
le fonctionnement normal de la justice
si on prend l'exemple du barreau de
versailles c'est des audiences qui sont
reportés exactement alors en réalité les
avocats se mobilisent depuis plus d'un
mois maintenant au niveau national c'est
une mobilisation de grande ampleur on
n'a jamais vu une telle mobilisation
depuis la libération
il ya plusieurs types de mouvements qui
sont lancés notamment au sein du barreau
de versailles
on a soit la grève des audiences qui
consiste à demander des renvoi
systématique de tous nos dossiers que ce
soit nos dossiers alors les gens pensent
souvent au pénal il n'y a pas que le
pénal il a également droit de la famille
droit du travail dont tu as c'est
vraiment une grève de toutes les
audiences et après il ya ce qu'on
appelle la grève du zèle qui consiste à
venir cette fois ci en grand nombre
d'avocats pour contraindre au renvoi ou
pour au contraire soulever un maximum de
moyens de droit pour alourdir les
audiences les audiences ne paraît encore
une fois toute nature pénale civile
ouais c'est ce qu'on fait à versailles
on est autour des cinq sens audience
aujourd'hui reporté alors j'ai pas de
chiffres exacts mais en tout cas vous
voilà en tout cas c'est ça épuise ne
serait ce qu'au sein du barreau de
versailles comme je vous l'aï dit ça
fait là on vient de voter aujourd'hui la
reconduction de la grève jusqu'à lundi
prochain donc on va être quasiment à
cinq semaines de grève et que nous on
appelle la grève dure ça veut dire que
c'est vraiment un renvoi de tous et donc
normalement dans toutes les audiences
vous avez des demandes de renvoi de la
part de mes confrères en soutien à ce
mouvement là donc ça donne un premier
élément de réponse en tout cas sur la
réponse apportée à part edouard philippe
à cette contestation le bilan que vous
faites un mois justement après le début
de cette mobilisation
on fait un triste constat qui est quand
on s'oppose à un véritable mur de la
part du
gouvernement on a donc nous notre
profession est divisée au sein du
barreau qui sont ensuite représenté au
niveau national parce qu'on appelle le
cnb le conseil national des barreaux qui
depuis quatre semaines a eu des formes
de rencontres avec d'abord notre mini de
la justice madame b loubet et l'a
récemment depuis une semaine avec le
premier ministre edouard philippe est en
réalité on alors ils se rencontrent ils
échangent mais absolument rien qui en
ressort depuis cinq semaines on a
exactement les mêmes propositions à
coups de communiqués de presse
respectifs qu'ils disent
en réalité à chaque fois la même chose
donc pour ce qui est de la négociation
est en fait on n'a même plus de
négociations pour ce qui est des changes
avec le gouvernement c'est c'est
impossible manifestement on doit s'y
résoudre
maintenant nous au sein de notre barreau
on envisage désormais de parler plus
avec nos députés où nos sénateurs qui
seront en fait l'étape d'après pour
espérer voilà avoir un échange avec des
personnes qui pourront influencer cette
réforme pas avec des actions pour le
moins original on a vu un saut en
parachute
quel lien qui vous a soutenu voilà en
sautant en parachute est également un
flash mob qui a été effectuée devant les
grilles du château de versailles
téléverser parler de vous il n'est pas
en fait on se rend compte que
malheureusement on est une profession
qui a du mal à se faire entendre parce
que les gens ont du mal à sortir de
cette idée de la vocal quand on pense à
un avocat on pense à un anti richissime
sauf que quand on regarde concrètement
les chiffres les avocats on est pas
richissime le revenu médian d'un avocat
ses quarante mille euros par an médian
ça veut dire qu'il y en a autant qui
gagne otsuka au dessus 40 mille euros
c'est qu'on n'est qu'à moment du magot
comme on peut imaginer
voilà donc on souffre de ce préjudice un
peu de d'image et donc on essaye de
faire parler de nous de manière un peu
plus ludique
donc vous avez parlé en effet du flash
mob de notre barreau à versailles il ya
d'autres barreaux qui ont fait des
actions un petit peu des communications
un peu plus originale pour faire parler
un peu de nous dans les mains
ah vous avez béthune et bordeaux qui ont
fait des dons du sang en se disant bas
quitte à être seigner autant qu on donne
notre sang pour des causes utiles
vous avez le havre qui a dansé les
confrères du havre qui ont dansé en tutu
pour faire un petit clin d'oeil aux
danseurs de l'opéra de paris qui ont eux
obtenu de sortir du régime universel de
réforme des retraites voilà on essaye un
peu de devoir d'être un peu originaux
alors si on revient sur les origines de
la mobilisation va voir s'afficher une
animation un qui revient sur les
principaux points que prévoit cette
réforme des retraites notamment la fonte
des quarante deux régimes spéciaux
actuel en un seul nommé système
universel expliquez-nous
concrètement dans les grandes lignes
comment fonctionne le système actuel et
des avocats de retraite et pourquoi il
ne faut pas y toucher
alors ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que vous venez de parler de régimes
spéciaux nous les avocats et de manière
générale les professions libérales ne
sommes pas des régimes spéciaux mais des
régimes autonome et c'est très différent
parce que la caisse nationale des
avocats donc notre cas c'est la cnbf est
autogéré autofinancé depuis toujours
depuis sa création ça veut dire qu'on ne
coûte pas un euro à l'état
c'est uniquement les cotisations des
avocats tous les mois tous les
trimestres qui alimentent cette caisse
est cette caisse ensuite redistribuées
pour les confrères qui sont à la
retraite donc nous en coûte absolument
aucun euro à l'état et même au delà de
ça parce qu'on a été un petit peu
accuser de pas afin de ne pas faire
preuve de solidarité en refusant
d'intégrer le régime général
tous les ans on contribue à hauteur de
100 millions d'euros au bénéfice du
régime général
ça fonctionne très bien et ça fonctionne
c'est dommage de tout chef qu'est ce qui
trait quand même particulier c'est de
voir que le régime général
il est très difficile r&d que vous
regardez les régimes autonome donc pas
les régimes spéciaux les régimes
autonome comme nous par exemple les
avocats mais comme les infirmiers com
doute trouver d'autres professions on
est excédentaire et nous c'est vrai que
notre caisse elle est excédentaire
depuis 1948 et aujourd'hui elle totalise
un excédent de 2 milliards d'euros
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est extrêmement
attractif c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement veut pas discuter avec nous
c'est que quoi qu'on dise ils veulent c
2 milliards d'euros
et ils vont de les prendre par le
premier ministre lors film je disais
tout à l'heure a fait a transmis un
courrier à votre profession
pour faire quelques propositions en tout
cas pour compenser la hausse des
cotisations de retraite qui serait une
réalité pour votre profession c'est pas
suffisant en tout cas vous reconduisez
la grève en tout cas au barreau de
versailles alors en réalité à chaque
fois que ce soit la mini de la justice
ou premier ministre à chaque fois qu'on
a des communiqués de presse sur des
propositions d'aménagement on comprend
rien du tout et c'est pas nous qui c'est
tellement fou qu'on n'y comprend rien on
nous parle d'augmentation des assiettes
de diminution un peu la csg c'est
comment un surcoût de cotisation pour
les avocats aux revenus les plus hauts
voilà c'est serré piste évoquée mais en
réalité c'est tellement difficilement
concret qu'on n'arrive pas à comprendre
vraiment la mise en application
c'est la raison pour laquelle donc les
mesures dont vous parlez qui sont
l'objet d'une proposition du premier
ministre on a reçu ça en gros cette nuit
vers 22 heures
notre instance nationale dont je vous ai
parlé le conseil national des barreaux
se réunit aujourd'hui demain au sein
d'assemblées générales pour étudier
concrètement et faire les simulations de
calculs pour voir un petit peu comment
on va se positionner
on n'a pas une position de principe
d'être en blocage et de la d'embêter
tout le monde on considère juste que
notre autonomie n'a pas de prix et quand
elles coûtent rien à personne et on a
nos confrères qui s'est rendu célèbre
xavier autant on dise en foutez nous la
paix au ministre mais c'est exactement
ça on veut garder notre autonomie après
s'y être des aménagements on pourra en
parler mais en tout cas notre autonomie
elle et elle est indispensable en l'état
on l'a compris une grève qui va
continuer pour les avocats et ceux du
barreau de versailles merci mme mandine
blondin d'être venu en parler en plateau
je rappelle que vous êtes à beaucaire au
barreau de versailles
et en cette journée nationale d'action
contre le projet de loi sur les
retraites il avait également cette
mobilisation depuis deux mois les
retraités ont interpellé les maires des
yvelines sur leur condition à leur
envoyant un courrier ils ont fait
connaître leur réponse la réponse des
élus aujourd'hui jeudi c'était devant la
mairie de versailles manon varaldo était
sur place dans les yvelines les
retraités de la cgt fsu fgr solidaire
est les serres ont attiré l'attention
des 260 maires du département sur leur
niveau de vie
ils se sont adressés à eux par courrier
quatorze maires ont répondu 9
soutiennent leurs revendications telles
le maire
de limay et maniant vivent ça fait des
années que les pensions des retraités
n'ont pas été revalorisés en plus ils
ont été impactés par une hausse de la
csg ce qui fait que pour trait un très
grand nombre de retraités non seulement
la pension n'a pas augmenté depuis très
longtemps mais elle baisse
il ya beaucoup de retraités qui sont
dans la misère et qu'il faut arrêter ce
cycle est maintenant revaloriser les
pensions les manifestants sont notamment
contre la retraite par points et
souhaite qu aucune pension soit
inférieur au smic une retraite qui soit
de toute façon n'ont pas à 64 ans mais
si possible même un retour à 60 ans je
pense que le système par points est
profondément injuste
nous participons à la vie mais commune
donc les retraités ne font pas de de
privilégiés nous sommes une partie de la
population et nous avons nos
revendications notre pouvoir d'achat
notre nos conditions de vie et aussi
pour faire soigner
parmi les manifestants des actifs eux
aussi contre cette réforme des retraites
et sa répartition comme ce mécanicien de
safran aircraft engine
c'est un travail pénible on n'est pas
reconnue en travaux pénibles en plus on
est la seule
on est le seul centre de sa première
cape town jean où les a pas de
reconnaissance sur les travaux pénibles
c'est inadmissible les retraités sont 17
millions en france
260 milles dans les yvelines dans
l'actualité un homme soupçonné de viol a
été placé en garde à vue ce mercredi les
faits se sont produits à guyancourt
dimanche matin au domicile de la victime
une policière selon les premiers
éléments de l'enquète elle a subi
l'agression au moment où elle rentrait
chez elle le suspect est un pompier de
paris il est interpellé sur son lieu de
travail
retrouvez grâce à un portrait robot et
aux caractéristiques de son véhicule la
sûreté départementale des yvelines est
en charge de l'enquêté
200 arbres plantés jeudi ce jeudi matin
à la forêt domaniale de port royal
attrape des collaborateurs de la société
pampers et leurs enfants ont participé à
cette opération accompagnée par l'office
national des forêts une initiative issue
d'un partenariat entre reforestation
entreprises à vocation sociale et
groupe spécialisé dans la production de
couches elle s'est engagé à planter
quatre vingt mille arbres dans le monde
écoutez ses interviews au micro de
nicolas landry la forêt nous tient à
coeur et notamment pour le bien-être des
générations futures et une partie non
enfin les couches sont composés de
cellulose la cellulose est issu du bois
et tout notre cellulose elle est
certifiée fsc c'est-à-dire forêts gérées
de manière durable et donc ça nous parce
ça nous paraissait faire complètement
sens avec nos engagements qui existait
déjà en la matière aujourd'hui il faut
restaurer l'équivalent de 10 millions de
kilomètres carrés pour rester dans les
clous de l'accord de paris c'est ce que
nous dit le giec les experts du climat
et notre objectif reste action c'est
donc de planter un milliard d'arbres à
horizon 2030 pour contribuer à cet
objectif de limitation des effets du
changement climatique et de restauration
des écosystèmes un éboulement de talus
qui a de lourdes conséquences il s'est
produit et mardi soir à proximité de la
gare sèvres ville d'avray dans les
hauts-de-seine
conséquence un trafic fortement perturbé
sur les lignes l ai eu du transilien
hier et ça se poursuit
aucun train ne circulera en gare de
versailles rive droite pour la ligne
elle pas de ligne lui non plus à
versailles chantiers jusqu'au moins
demain vendredi nos confrères de bfm
paris parle même d'un trafic perturbé
jusqu'au 24 février et les itinéraires
de substitution sont à consulter sur le
site transilien.com
[Musique]
on reste à versailles pour quelque chose
de plus positif avec mélanie poker
bonsoir ça alors pour ce rendez-vous
loisirs dont vous nous vous venez parler
chaque semaine on se range e ledy à
versailles le tournoi d'asma team est de
retour dans la cité royale
et oui pour cette troisième édition les
organisateurs ont vu plus grand depuis
deux ans le rendez-vous tourner autour
d'un singe eux alors stones ont pour
attirer un public un peu plus grand
public et faire se rencontrer plus de
joueurs il y a deux nouveaux tournois
qui sont proposés par ahmat hymne au
tour de league of legends et le deuxième
c'est pour les fans de football c'est
fifa va écouter le fait qu'il ait plus
de choix bas se permet aux de rassembler
et puis au niveau de pâques ou de
versailles c'est un petit peu la même
idée c'est qu'il avait eu des retours
comme quoi il y avait des gens qui
trouvent une initiative très bonne mais
comme c'était pas sur le jeu au pied qui
jouait bas ils se trouvent sur moi et
j'avais l'impression d'un peu moins
participer à la fête le jeu qu'on a fait
les deux premières années toujours la
personne parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
réussi à créer un rendez vous donc
l'idée ce n'est pas de tout perdre
mais voilà avec les nouveaux jeux
d'ouvrir à de nouvelles personnes
le tournoi débute à 13h mais pas
d'inscription à prévoir mélanie c'est
surtout de la détermination qu'il va
falloir montrer skaar matinée la mairie
de versailles ont choisi que
de faire que les tournois ça soit
gratuit alors elles sont pas extensibles
ses places pour être sûr de concourir il
faut arriver dès midi à l'hôtel de ville
pour s'inscrire il ya 104 places pour
league of legends 64 pour fifa et 32
pour aston alors autre particularité
cette année il n'y a pas de tournoi
différent entre les amateurs et les
professionnels
on peut donc se tester et demander des
conseils aux meilleurs joueurs présents
en grégory je sais de source sûre que
vous êtes un fan de fifa est ce que je
demande à ce qu'on veut garder une place
là-bas j'aimerais bien oui pourquoi pas
me tester avec quelques amateurs et
quelques initiés à fifa merci à mélanie
d'autres idées de sorties à retrouver
bien sûr dans votre émission le 7,8 à
loisir et c'est après ce journal la page
municipal pour clôturer cette édition à
la verrière une quatrième candidature
s'est lancé pour les élections
municipales gérard morfin propose une
liste citoyenne dont il révélera le
programme dans les semaines à venir les
détails avec marylène ya piccino ancien
premier adjoint derrière pierre c'est
l'un court avant de passer dans
l'opposition en montant une première
liste citoyenne en 2002 gérard morfin
présente à nouveau une liste citoyenne
pour les élections de 2020 il faut
maintenant quand on parle de démocratie
la vivre il a partagé
et ça fait partie de cet axe olad cette
idée là que même une campagne électorale
peut avoir des concepts citoyens une
liste est un programme qui seront
révélés au fur et à mesure mais déjà la
volonté d'établir des référents par
quartier pour une meilleure
représentativité de la commune trois
d'entre eux ont été présentés comme
aïcha nedjari une ancienne élue de la
majorité
moi je vais le quartier d'ordi parc
pourquoi parce que pendant de nombreuses
années j'étais présidente de
l'association des locataires
puis c'est pour ça que gérard est venu
me chercher pour être représentante de
ce quartier qui me tient qui me tiennent
à coeur et pouvoir le proposer et
n'ouvrira à d'autres quartiers de la
verrière qui sont vraiment cloisonné
aujourd'hui
pas d'étiquette politique la liste tient
à son identité citoyenne pour vivre et
partager la démocratie je fais pas tu
lui dis que j'ai jamais fait politique
et je suis pas là pour faire de la
politique est comme gérard et dans ce
top 6 heures et les gens sont dans cette
optique là et aujourd'hui c'est sa vie
des citoyennes c'est un acteur de sa vie
pouvoir apporter quelque chose
pour l'heure les 31 non nécessaires ne
figure pas sur la liste mais sont en
voie de l'être dans la commune de la
verrière trois autres listes sont
aujourd'hui déclaré du côté de magny les
hameaux peut être trois listes en lice
pour ces élections municipales bonsoir
dominique gradins
bonsoir vous avez été conseiller
municipal de la commune entre 1995 et
2001 dans la majorité de l'ancien maire
jacques los dioses vous êtes en train de
constituer une liste qui s'appelle manie
le bon sens pourquoi vous lancer dans
cette campagne des municipales
et bien en fait donc j'ai été conseiller
municipal de 95 à 2001
et puis en 2001 bon je ne suis pas
représenté personne ne me non plus
demandé de repartir ce je suis en fait
un électron libre
c'est à dire que je dis un peu ce que je
pense et donc mais ça s'est très bien
passé en fait non je me suis endormi en
toute confiance avec donc le maire
jacques neau lloze qui avait fait des
choses intéressantes importante et il
avait fait notamment le domaine du mes
rentes et le
la réhabilitation complète et je me suis
dit que ça allait être la même chose
avec le maire actuel
mais en décembre je me suis réveillé un
peu en sursaut en voyant que la ferme de
gomberville qui était en fait une
pépinière doublé d'un centre équestre et
bien que ce tout cet ensemble qui avait
été présenté par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines allaient être
livrés un promoteur et en faire car deux
cas c'est aussi ce qui se passe sur la
ferme de bus loyal or elle ne sera fait
finalement pas vendu par l'agglomération
de 50 ans nîmes qui l'a confirmé il ya
notamment un projet de pérennisation
agricole de formation et de tourisme et
d'insertion qui est en cours ça c'est
pas suffisant a en fait ils à ces choses
là apparemment ont été annoncés il ya
très peu de temps parce que en fait moi
quand j'en ai parlé c'était encore rien
n'était fait c'est à dire que depuis
trois ans les terres sont en friche il y
a quatre hectares et demi donc ça
pouvait accueillir deux maraîchers et
puis également tous les locaux qui sont
en fait les anciens locaux de l'opéra de
l'établissement public d'aménagement de
saint quentin en yvelines qui seront à
l'abandon depuis trois ans donc de payer
par des choses plus plus vite peut-être
mais il fallait faire en fait des choses
beaucoup plus vite surtout qu'avant il y
avait les jardins de cocagne qui était
dessus les jardins de cocagne ont eu des
problèmes et sont partis mais rien n'a
été fait non plus pour les pérenniser
pour les garder donc ce qui a été fait
c'est de faire ce qui s'appelle une
ferme périurbaines qui a coûté quand
même huit cent mille euros au niveau de
la commune et cette ferme périurbaines
sert à très peu de personnes parce qu'en
fait à l'accueil de maraîchers
actuellement l'un pour alimenter une
amap sur magny les hameaux d'une
centaine d'adhérents et l'autre
maraîchers une amap de guyancourt donc
les hemani quoi paix en fait des choses
fortement alors que ce repas dû être le
camp sur votre liste parlant devant
juste la constitution de votre liste qui
je le précise ce sera sans étiquette où
en êtes-vous est ce que vous êtes non
encore des ventes neuf non
même qu'il faut pour se présenta manière
je suis direct jeudi vraiment ce que je
pense ce que je fais donc effectivement
j'en suis encore loin
pourquoi parce que les gens j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont peur de venir
[Musique]
par rapport à leurs voisins par rapport
à leurs amis de dire bien la liste je
quitte en fait aussi bien une ni vague
de gauche c'est à dire mon les deux
listes au opposés vont être sans
étiquette mais en fait l'une est une
liste de gauche et l'autre de la liste
de droite qui était donc le maire forte
en génération bertrand ou l'autre côté
le conseil municipal d'opposition et
lionel lindemann c'est ça tout à fait
donc ça va être deux listes une de
gauche mais la gauche un peu plus
radicale 1 avec la france insoumise et
génération le pc ne va quasiment plus
être représenté le ps je ne sais pas et
de l'autre côté c'est la droite avec en
marche alors le programme il est en
cours de constitution il nous reste
environ 3 minutes dans cet entretien
l'idée forte en tout cas ce que vous
voulez défendre c'est la démocratie
participative mettre en place notamment
des comités participatif et et
consultatif comment ça pourrait
fonctionner en fait en s'inspirant
beaucoup de ce qui se fait aux molières
la ville des molières le maire
département de l'essonne département de
l'essonne mais qui juste à côté de magny
les hameaux a lancé cette démocratie
participative
depuis déjà un ou deux mandats et ça
marche très bien
à tel point qu'il a créé ce qui
s'appelle aussi des communes et des
citoyens une association qui regroupe
sur toute la france des gens qui veulent
faire justement cette démocratie
participative
il ya aussi une autre idée sa
transparence et laissant une
transparence c'est-à-dire que moi je
pense qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
transparence actuellement à la mairie à
la ville de magny les hameaux et je
pense qu'il faudrait une transparence
notamment pour avoir les subventions de
toutes les associations à savoir les
coûts exacts de tout le set ferme
périurbaines et y'a pas que la ferme
périurbaines il y a également le plateau
de chemin cours qui a été réaménagé en
faisant trois trous de golf et le golf
il faut savoir que le golf national et
sur la commune donc pourquoi aller créer
trois trousses doit coller guyancourt
aussi un autre
ça cheval on va dire sur les deux
communes où il survit été localisé sur
la commune de guyancourt
juste un mot parce que c'est important
il ya une double identité à magny les
hameaux de la commune qui est aussi bien
membre du parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse et de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout comment
elle doit se positionner justement avec
109 être ça s'était très bien positionné
jusqu'à présent c'est-à-dire en fait
jacques l'eau lloze avait lancé l'idée
que magny les hameaux et est une petite
ville à la campagne et ça se passait
très bien mais maintenant en fait la
petite ville
eh bien elle fait un petit peu n'importe
quoi et puis elle la campagne depuis que
j'ai reparlé d'agricole eh bien on
commence à revenir un petit peu à dire
la ferme de gomberville la ferme de
bulles loyer on va faire de l'agricole
mais c'est pas maintenant c'était avant
qu'il fallait y penser
dernière chose est-ce que vous avez des
rendez vous de prévu des réunions pour
présenter le projet aux habitants
manicouagan
alors j'ai une rang un rendez vous ce
samedi à la salle madeleine landais et
puis au village donc au restaurant
scolaire
rosa bonheur au village de magny les
hameaux et on retrouve l'ensemble des
agendas de campagne des candidats aux
municipales sur notre site internet tv
78 points comme merci dominique grappin
d'être venu parler de votre candidature
manie le bon sens vous êtes donc
potentiel troisième candidat pour le
scrutin des municipales
et je précise que sont engagés également
dans la campagne à magny les hameaux le
maire sortant bertrand ou lyon et le
conseiller municipal d'opposition lionel
l'île de man et direction elle encourt
pour refermer ce journal afin de
connaître les enjeux des élections
municipales dans la commune colline
commissariat d'agglomération éducation
rénovation du pont de lavilledieu ont
fait le point avec wilfrid richy
elancourt 25000 habitants membres de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines devrait être à l'honneur en
2024 lors des jeux olympiques si
seulement les épreuves de vtt ne sont
pas délocaliser à chamonix le dossier
paris 2024 semblait définitif le manque
de clarté des instances olympiques agace
région département et fédération
française de cyclisme mais ravi
certaines associations le prochain maire
devra donc trancher défendre ce projet
au favoriser une délocalisation des
épreuves
autre grand projet à suivre
l'élaboration du commissariat de
circonscription qui regroupera les
effectifs d'elancourt de trappes et de
guyancourt le projet
date de 2005 l'état a donné en 2019 son
agrément
elle a aussi le choix du prochain maire
sera déterminant l'équipement est
annoncée pour l'instant comme un lieu
d'expérimentation des nouvelles
technologies à commissariat du futur et
plus largement la ville de demain à
imaginer les questions environnementales
et écologiques s'invite dans le débat a
de la mise en place du bio dans les
menus des cantines à l'accompagnement du
développement de nouveaux modes de
transport côté transports un point
semble avancer le doublement du pont de
lavilledieu vers la verrière pas reste à
travailler sur les aménagements un
quartier sera aussi à repenser lors de
la prochaine mandature celui des quatre
à avoir une réflexion complète doit être
mené sur cette zone d'activités enfin
durant cette campagne les questions
d'éducation de santé sont aussi abordés
par les candidats dans leur programme
sans oublier un dossier qui occupe
également la campagne dans la ville
voisine de maurepas celui de la
construction d'un nouveau centre
aqualudique et dont la livraison est
annoncée pour 2022
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]